okay what are just to go over it again
what are the actual statistics on um
police killing people according to a
Washington Post database and this is far
from a far-right organization that's
trying to you know get police off the
hook twenty five unarmed White's were
killed by cops last year fourteen
unarmed blacks were killed the whole
year across the whole country and it
would be totally irrational to assume
that all of those killings were
automatically unjustified just because
the person was unarmed remember that
Obama's DOJ found that the killing of
Michael Brown who was unarmed was
justified because he was rushing at and
trying to kill a cop so many of the
unarmed killings are like that you've
got a small small small minority of
police killings that are unarmed and a
small minority of those that are
questionable and that's it so the facts
don't support these claims of oppression
and yet you've got people marching
through the street with signs like this
you see these signs all over the place
stop killing us the signs say who are
you talking to who is killing you
what are you talking about the vast
majority of people of any race who are
killed are killed by other private
citizens of that same race so who are
you talking to are you protesting
against murder in general are you saying
that all murder has to stop an order for
for you to no longer be oppressed well
that would be ridiculous enough as it is
because murder will always happen in in
human society especially in a country of
330 million people but it's even more
ridiculous than that because these
protesters with these signs aren't
talking about murder in general they're
talking about an imaginary epidemic of
white people and white cops going on
racist rampages and murdering black
people an article in the Atlantic also
makes this claim it says right at the
top it says I want white people to stop
killing us they're not it's a very rare
occur
and that is extremely rare more black
people are killing white people than
white people are killing black people
and in fact considering that there are
so many fewer black people in the
country the statistical likelihood that
a black person kills a white person is
exponentially higher than the other way
around this again is the reality plain
as day
but the reality doesn't matter here's a
tweet from McDonald's McDonald's yes
that McDonald's the one that you know
sells Big Macs but they've been tweeting
far-left
you know BLM propaganda videos for the
last few weeks and here's one of them hi
Mario Jones the founder of transflash
media in this black lives matter moment
black trans women have a very simple
message stop killing us we can't expect
others to care about us more than we
care about ourselves we're all free or
none of us is stop killing us there it
is again but who are you talking to who
is killing you that there is no epidemic
of anti-trans murders it doesn't exist
yes trans people are murdered everyone
is murdered every group of people is
susceptible to being murdered because
we're all mortal and we live in a human
society where crime happens ok but you
know in in terms of their bit of their
being an epidemic of trans people being
murdered by trans folks who are just out
killing trans people that almost never
happens that is extremely extremely rare
the vast majority of trans people who
are killed are killed by in domestic
violence or in drug-related or
prostitution related killings but let's
go back to the fact so you got the video
itself the claim being made in the video
which is which is absurd but the very
fact that this hysterical paranoia is
being propagated by McDonald's one of
the largest and richest corporations in
America I think that tells you something
as well and we'll talk about that and
second this video is sponsored by blink
sale the revolutionary invoicing
software for contractors and small
businesses spend less time billing and
more time making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description